what about vaping if you had a look at
any of the signs from vaping I it's kind
of a little bit of a moral panic at the
moment if you look at certain areas of
the ancestral paleo World on the
internet uh what's your thoughts on
vaping and its potential let's come back
to kind of the risk reward Matrix right
so again I view everything through this
two by two so
what's the risk is it closer to getting
hit by a tricycle or getting hit by a
train and what's the reward is it
picking up a dollar or is it picking up
a gold coin
so I think that the I don't think we
have sufficient data to say that it's
picking up that it's getting hit by a
tricycle
um I don't think the industry is
standardized enough to be sure that what
is being inhaled is sufficiently clean
maybe it is maybe some companies are
better than others I mean we could talk
about that all day long but I'm not
personally willing to put my trust in
that in that market in that
infrastructure in those companies
whatsoever so so for me personally this
would be a no-brainer there's no upside
in it to me
what would you be concerned about going
into your body it's not just the
nicotine it's the stuff oh no first of
all nicotine I love like I'm all about
nicotine how do you use nicotine in a
safe way
um I would chew gum or I would use I use
like a lozenge or I'd um there's like
these little patches that you you know
kind of suck on Zin pouch what have you
found is your favorite brand for those
um
I'm blanking on the name of the brand
they come in a little round colorful
thing I don't remember the name of the
brand got you and you're using three
makes five mix
um unfortunately that's the maybe I
haven't bought in a while from these
guys I bought so many the first time by
accident that I'm still living off the
last two years worth I literally just
like an idiot accidentally bought 10
times more than I could prep up yeah so
um Unfortunately they only come in
sevens which is no way dude I would you
can't do it all at once that would be in
my mouth for 30 seconds and then I would
have to take it yeah yeah so I go in out
in out and out and out
um I think they have a four as well so
it's a little bit more manageable yeah
but truthfully like I think two
milligrams is sort of the right dose one
to two milligrams is probably the sweet
spot and then you don't need to think
about taking it in and out yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um so so no to be clear like the the
nicotine is not the problem right uh
it's the it's just like with cigarettes
nicotine is not the problem with
cigarettes yes there's an addictive
component to it the problem is the
toxicity of the vehicle that's
delivering the nicotine in the form of
tobacco well with vaping I don't have
any sense of what's happening when you
have a heated metal filament that is
burning combustible products some of
which I may or may not be inhaling
through a filter like what I'm saying is
not that I know there's something wrong
with this but I'm saying I have no
confidence in that industry to regulate
itself or our regulatory agency to
regulate them and therefore
because I don't know where it is on the
risk parameter but I definitely don't
feel comfortable saying it's getting hit
by a tricycle it could be getting hit by
you know a small car it could be getting
hit by a train for all I know we you
know it's just an unknown and then you
know how would I justify it well unless
I felt that the reward Matrix was
picking up gold coins it just doesn't
justify it to me so
is that a moral panic I don't think so I
think it's just saying like what's the
risk reward trade-off for it Justified
skepticism perhaps uh another Revolution
that's going on at the moment which I've
been at the sort of front row seat of
has been alcohol and the reduction in
the consumption of alcohol I think
people realizing uh
it's no surprise that it's a a really
dangerous risk but people who considered
that one drink was okay that two glasses
of wine because there's some Resveratrol
coming from the red grapes etc etc
um I was a club promoter for a very long
time so I was in the trenches partying
hard for all of my 20s which is why your
uh 90th to 100th year estimation I think
is unfortunately going to be a little
bit too generous but
I went sober for six months really loved
it
um most to do with the lifestyle changes
cognitive cognitive improvements uh what
it meant in terms of habit in terms of
consistency energy money time all that
stuff came back to drinking didn't like
it went back to sober for another six
months came back to drinking for a
couple of months didn't like it did a
thousand days sober uh I never had a an
issue with substances but just really
loved what it had done for me and you
know
five years hands six years hence now the
low end no movement seems to be really
really gaining speed
is that so why is it so surprising like
why is it that something that ostensibly
obviously wasn't that good for us is now
only just beginning to kind of
get some momentum of people thinking oh
maybe this thing that makes me feel like
a total pile of dog the next day is
something that I shouldn't take all the
time I don't know I can't speak to it
the only thing I could speculate is that
with the uh with the rise of sleep
trackers I think you really have some
objective data on the downside and I
don't I don't think anybody who's worn a
whoop who doesn't look at their heart
rate variability pre and post alcohol
consumption or the fragmentation of
their sleep is not saying what the hell
it's insane why is it such an impact for
the unindoctrinated amongst us let's say
that you've got a heart rate variability
of 70. if you were to have two glasses
of beer or two small glasses of wine on
an evening finishing at nine or ten pm
and then go to sleep on the night it
wouldn't surprise me if from 70 your
heart rate variability is down in the
30s yeah or the 40s what is happening
inside of the body that's causing that
to happen so alcohol is metabolized
um into different elements but but one
of the metabolic byproducts of alcohol
is quite toxic and
um I suspect I don't know but I suspect
what's happening is the toxicity of that
is changing the autonomic nervous system
so in what you want what you want to be
doing when you're sleeping is in a
maximally parasympathetic State
um that the so-called rest and digest
State and that's really what heart rate
variability is measuring right heart
rate variability along with other things
such as heart rate itself and
temperature respiratory rate are proxies
for your autonomic nervous system and
anytime those things move in the wrong
direction so heart rate goes up heart
rate variability goes down respiratory
rate goes up temperature goes up all of
those things happen when you drink
that to me is a very strong signal that
something about the toxicity of the
metabolic byproduct of ethanol is
putting the body into more of a
fight-or-flight response as opposed to a
rest and digest response it's so
hilarious that the thing that a lot of
people use and has been used for a long
time I can't get to sleep I'll have a
glass of whiskey uh isn't really aiding
with sleep it's just sedating people
yeah that's the Insidious thing about it
right is people confuse sedation
Consciousness and sleep and I I you know
I'd love to tell the glib anecdote right
which is like if I hit you over the head
with a baseball bat you would lie
motionless for 12 hours but of course
there's no confusion over the fact that
you are not sleeping and nothing about
that experience is good for your brain
or your body in terms of rest and
recovery so yes alcohol is very sedating
but it doesn't promote sleep in the way
that we know sleep Works in terms of its
stages and its functionality in terms of
healing what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]